let's talk about what you missed in
politics
I completely forgot about politics wait
so who dropped wait so you're telling so
gay so can I guess yeah how many dropped
during three three well small well was
out by the time I went off so I'm
getting all three dropped and you
already told me that Williamson is still
in now she didn't make the debate but
she's still in oh all right so she's
done then so that's in front well once
you start getting out of the debate they
never let you back in and then it just
feeds on the fundraiser she's got love
out but she's got the power of love just
got the power of jealousy yeah
so three dropped out well I'm guessing
it's it's got to be like Inslee and
anslee's out enslie's out okay then
there's the other guy that's sort of
Inslee like he would give me one of the
you know what I'll do something crazy
that shouldn't go ahead I'll pick one
how about Tulsi that would be depressing
she did not make the debate however
she's polling above 2% in like 20 of the
early states the Democrats just picked
two states where she wasn't pulling at
least 2% so she's not getting in but
she's not leaving I think I think she is
the one war like she is she you know she
left what were you here when she left to
go back to serve in the military
she left the campaign trail for two
weeks to go back to the military and do
you know her I don't I don't know what
her reserve status is but she had to go
back she did it with a smile on her face
left no big deal she just left and I saw
her and I thought the Democrats are so
foolish that woman could act she cuz she
doesn't hate the country everybody else
seems to hate the country she doesn't
now I don't agree with her own policies
but she seems like a normal human being
and I really think if you just had a
normal human being so many people would
Russia you know what I knew they were
gonna boot her no matter what because
this is about how corrupt the DNC is
when when she started getting a little
traction online and you know I've been
pretty good I think it over the last
couple years tracking when somebody
starts somebody started getting a little
something and you doesn't sort of see it
I've seen this with Jordan and so many
these people she started getting a
little buzzed and next thing you know
BuzzFeed conservatives secretly love
tulsi gabbard you know like all these
stories that suddenly the frogs and the
trolls love her and it's like ah they
got the memo she's starting to catch on
with some interesting people she
wouldn't be a vote for a conservative
but she would be somebody that you could
go okay you believe she loves the
country that she believes she will put
the country first which was a big thing
with Donald Trump you know he nobody
thought he hated America they just loved
himself more but he didn't hate America
that was a big deal but you know there's
a there's a really ironic position for
the Democrats right now which is that
someone like her who was really running
as anti-war that was her main thing well
Trump has not been for war he called off
the Iran strike we seemed to be
negotiating with North Korea does anyone
think we're gonna nation-build under
Donald Trump oh you should have sue you
should have heard his speech I think it
was on Friday when he he talked about in
this nowhere today I couldn't find
anywhere on the end of the Afghan war he
said we are not nation-building again so
but then when a Democrat comes out
really anti-war well how does that even
make sense anymore now that's not me
with Trump so you then you again you get
this like crazy situation that no matter
what Trump says you think that's why is
it don't you think that's why people are
starting like to be uncomfortable
because they're like a crap I agree with
Glenn Beck or oh crap I agree with Dave
Rubin and we're very close we don't
agree on everything but we have certain
pretty big principles in common
that everyone else seemed to have
abandoned let I'll give you two people
that you know and like when Bridget fed
Izzy when I did her podcast was I was
before you did her podcast and she said
to me that she I mean you could listen
to it where she says she was shocked
that she liked you and the other one is
my good friend people goes in well I
love and adore Philip both of it yeah I
love both of them I do too he even was
saying well I can't believe it
but here I am in this this is a good man
this is and I think I'm pretty sure you
might have did you write the foreword
for their book are you you you I did
you did something yeah you did something
it's like that's that's the weird a lot
look all the people that are good it's
great that's good it's great because
that's I think where the country is they
don't want to aid people anymore and
we're not these cartoon characters
alright so Williamson out of the debate
and tulsi out of the bait but they're
both still in it I got it obviously
right the other two that might have
dropped did klore bhature hick Oh hit in
the looper okay I couldn't go up with
the name Hickenlooper and Gillibrand
yeah can I just
yes please Kristen Jill and Brad you
wonder how ridiculous her campaign was
so I don't have my phone for you know
for 30-something David I could find this
here
Kristen chillin brand where is this has
been texting me I don't know or her
people I got on their list and they've
been texting me and I repeatedly told
them in text stop messaging me they said
she's the only one that can stop Trump
blah blah blah no matter how many times
I tell them miss please Gillibrand stop
they won't
yeah I keep getting text fundraising
text so I guess what you're telling is
I'm not gonna get those fun you're not
gonna get those funder you don't have a
problem Biden here all right doesn't
matter so it looks like believe it looks
like Biden is still clearly head however
man he's he is hurting I think he I
don't think I something seems
cognitively not quite right I don't
think you really would have missed have
you seen him in the last 30 no is he is
he worse worse I think they asked him
last night he's the last chance for any
blue dog design Emma crap they they
asked him last night you know why do you
want to be President and he couldn't
really come up with an answer cuz he
doesn't want to be he doesn't want it if
he wanted to be president he would have
ran when Obama went out the first right
he didn't want to the the powers that be
whatever that is I don't mean that in a
conspiratorial way I mean that the the
last remaining decent Democrats that
were the people in charge in the Star
Chamber yeah yeah exactly
we're going holy [ __ ] we're about to
hand this thing to a OC and Omar and the
rest of these true radicals who are
going to destroy everything that is good
about America they looked around and
they said is there one decent Democrat
and they said can we resurrect JFK is
there anything left
you know commuting he's alive
anything else related I know yeah but
but Biden was basically dragged in it's
obvious he doesn't want to do it it's
obvious he was the last year is why he
heard thing when he said that but he
told Obama please come on please his
wife two weeks ago was meeting was doing
a fundraiser and she said look I know
there's a lot of candidates that you
might like much more than my husband but
he's the only guy that can win so you
got to get behind him that's your pitch
she liked me Wow what I mean that's
really it's sad and it's pathetic and
it's you know and that's the other thing
the last night that it was I think July
31st just as I was going off the grid
was a democratic debate I think it was
the second night of and I wasn't really
paying attention excited to tie up so
many loose ends but when I had it on in
the background it was like I just kept
thinking why would I want any of these
people to be more involved in my life I
don't want Trump to be more involved in
my life by the way either I don't love
these people and they keep saying they
can solve all of your problems right
have they ever solved any of their
problems as Bernie Sanders ever created
one job have these people have they ever
done anything but if they only had four
point two trillion dollars to do this
and then it's like there's no no I said
to I guess I am feeling sharp after hey
I I was I I said once what's Trump was
elected I called all my liberal friends
and I said see how you feel right now
that's the way the country has felt on
the other half for eight years yeah
don't I can't believe it
don't kick them while they're down don't
do it it's a huge mistake none of them
none of them listen to it but it's you
we're repeating exactly the same
patterns just in Reverse times a
thousand well one of the things that I
really hope I can do in the next year
and I and I'm becoming one of those
people who says I write about this in my
book but I do write about this book is
one of the things that I want to see
happen now is on the right so not really
like the libertarian so like you who I
the libertarians are always decent and
tolerant I find all
things but one of the things that I
think sometimes libertarians have the
same disease as Republicans and
Democrats
you're not libertarian enough right so
they have a strange purity test yes
you're like because then it's like how
far do you want to go till we're in Mad
Max right that's what I would say but
right but one of the things that I think
would would really help a lot of what
you're concerned about here is is if the
Conservatives could say you know what
we're gonna carve out a little more
space for some secular conservatives for
some gay conservatives just that we
don't have to agree with everything even
even say a pro-choice conservative which
I know would be a it makes no sense in a
certain way but we're going to carve out
a little bit of Speight not put it in
the party platform but just know it's
all Trump did with with Peter teal yeah
I mean he is I don't know how that guy
gets the most evil - gays ever award but
he does and you're like wait what what
has he done what has he ever said here -
Oh at the RNC convention right now gay
man standing I mean that was fantastic
fantastic the world didn't cave in on
itself and yet now everybody in the gay
rights industry and I use that word in
industry it's an industry
[Music]